Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, Episode Five: development cooperation, and the focus on Africa.
Denmark gives financial support to many of the world's poorest countries.
This support is called international development cooperation.
Denmark is one of a few countries in the world that meet the UN's target that countries should give 0.7 percent of gross national income, GNI, in development aid.
In 2026, that corresponds to about 23 billion kroner.
The aims of Danish aid are, for example, to fight poverty, create jobs, trade and investment, help with the green transition, fight corruption, promote democracy and human rights, and women's and girls' rights.
Some of the Danish development aid is given as direct aid to the developing countries.
Denmark gives, for example, money directly to the developing countries, to humanitarian work, and to the work carried out by civil society organisations.
Denmark also gives aid in the form of contributions to international organisations such as the EU, the UN and the World Bank.
Part of the money in 2026 is also given to help Ukraine with humanitarian aid and the rebuilding of the country.
Since 1971, Danida has been responsible for Danish development policy.
Danida is an independent department under the Ministry of Foreign Affairs.
At the Danish embassies and representations abroad there are both local and Danish dispatched staff who handle the development cooperation with the individual country.
Now, the focus on Africa.
Africa is the part of the world that has historically had the biggest focus in Danish development policy, and which has received most of the Danish development aid.
That is connected, among other things, with Africa being a neighbour to Europe, and with what happens in Africa being able to have great importance for Europe, and thereby for Denmark.
There is a big difference between the 54 African countries, but overall Africa is the world's poorest continent, and in several places there are civil wars and other conflicts.
And the population is growing fast, and with it Africa's importance.
Africa's population has almost doubled over the last 25 years, from 835 million in 2001 to 1.6 billion in 2026.
Towards 2050, according to the UN, a further population increase of almost 1 billion is expected, to a total of 2.5 billion.
That creates on the one hand the opportunity for more economic growth, more trade and more investment, but also increases the risk of bigger problems with climate change and poverty, which can also lead to more people fleeing or migrating, and some towards Europe via the life-threatening routes across the Mediterranean.
In 2024, about 130,000 illegal arrivals from Africa to Europe were registered.
The average African emits far fewer of the greenhouse gases that are the main cause of climate change than, for example, the average American, Chinese or European.
But Africa's emissions are expected to grow in the coming decades.
And in any case it is in Africa that some of the worst consequences of climate change are felt, in the form of, for example, floods, extreme heat, failed harvests and more areas with desert.
A closer cooperation between the European and African countries is therefore meant to ensure, among other things, that Europe becomes the preferred partner and does not lose political influence.
The Danish government presented in 2024 a new and comprehensive "Strategy for a strengthened Danish engagement with the African countries".
It proposes that Denmark engages more in Africa and also focuses on creating equal partnerships with the African countries.
The strategy continues the support, while focusing on peace and security, the fight against climate change, and better opportunities for investment in African countries, economic growth and more trade with Danish companies.
Other aims are also to create more exchange of culture and education, and to reduce the number of illegal migrants towards Europe.
Here is your recap for Episode Five.
Denmark meets the UN's target of 0.7 percent of gross national income in development aid, which in 2026 is about 23 billion kroner.
Danida has been responsible for Danish development policy since 1971, as a department under the Ministry of Foreign Affairs.
Africa is the continent with the biggest focus.
There are 54 African countries.
The population grew from 835 million in 2001 to 1.6 billion in 2026, and is expected to reach 2.5 billion by 2050.
About 130,000 illegal arrivals from Africa to Europe were registered in 2024.
In 2024, the government presented a new strategy for a strengthened Danish engagement with the African countries.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which continent receives the largest share of Denmark's development aid?
Option A: Asia.
Option B: South America.
Option C: Africa.
[DA] Hvilket kontinent modtager den største andel af Danmarks udviklingsbistand?  A: Asien  |  B: Sydamerika  |  C: Afrika
The answer is C: Africa.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Afrika
That's the end of this part.
Well done.